[Music]
for almost a decade
scientists chased the source of a deadly
new virus through china's tallest
mountains
and most isolated caverns they finally
found it here
in the bats of shitao cave the virus in
question
was a coronavirus that caused an
epidemic of severe acute respiratory
syndrome
or sars in 2003.
coronaviruses are a group of viruses
covered in little protein spikes
that look like a crown or corona in
latin
there are hundreds of known
coronaviruses
seven of them infect humans and can
cause disease
the coronavirus sars kovi causes
sars mares kobe causes mares
and sars cov2 causes the disease
covid19 of the seven human coronaviruses
four cause colds mild highly contagious
infections of the nose and throat
two infect the lungs and cause much more
severe
illnesses the seventh which causes
covert 19
has features of each it spreads easily
but can severely impact the lungs
when an infected person coughs droplets
containing the virus spray out
the virus can infect a new person when
the droplets enter their nose or mouth
coronaviruses transmit best in enclosed
spaces
where people are close together cold
weather keeps their delicate casing from
drying out
enabling the virus to survive for longer
between hosts
while uv exposure from sunlight may
damage it
these seasonal variations matter more
for established viruses
but because no one is yet immune to a
new virus it has so many potential hosts
that it doesn't need ideal conditions to
spread
in the body the protein spikes in bed in
the host cells
and fuse with them enabling the virus to
hijack the host cells machinery to
replicate its own genes
coronaviruses store their genes on rna
all viruses are either rna viruses or
dna viruses
rna viruses tend to be smaller with
fewer genes
meaning they infect many hosts and
replicate quickly in those hosts
in general rna viruses don't have a
proofreading mechanism
whereas dna viruses do so
when an rna virus replicates it's much
more likely to have mistakes
called mutations many of these mutations
are useless
or even harmful but some make the virus
better suited for certain environments
like a new host species epidemics often
occur when a virus jumps from animals to
humans
this is true of the rna viruses that
cause the ebola
zika and sars epidemics and the covert
19 pandemic
once in humans the virus still mutates
usually not enough to create a new virus
but enough to create variations or
strains of the original one
coronaviruses have a few key differences
from most rna viruses
they're some of the largest meaning they
have the most genes
that creates more opportunity for
harmful mutations
to counteract this risk coronaviruses
have a unique feature
an enzyme that checks for replication
errors and corrects mistakes
this makes coronaviruses much more
stable with a slower mutation rate
than other rna viruses while this may
sound formidable
the slow mutation rate is actually a
promising sign when it comes to
disarming them
after an infection our immune systems
can recognize
germs and destroy them more quickly if
they infect us again
so they don't make us sick but mutations
can make a virus less recognizable to
our immune systems
and therefore more difficult to fight
off they can also make antiviral drugs
and vaccines less effective
because they're tailored very
specifically to a virus
that's why we need a new flu vaccine
every year the influenza virus mutates
so quickly that new strains pop
up constantly the slower mutation rate
of coronaviruses
means our immune systems drugs and
vaccines
might be able to recognize them for
longer after infection
and therefore protect us better still
we don't know how long our bodies remain
immune to different coronaviruses
there's never been an approved treatment
or vaccine for a coronavirus
we haven't focused on treating the ones
that cause colds and though scientists
began developing treatments for sars and
mares
the epidemics ended before those
treatments completed clinical trials
as we continue to encroach on other
animals habitats
some scientists say a new coronavirus
jumping to humans
is inevitable but if we investigate
these unknowns
it doesn't have to be devastating
students and teachers all over the world
did their part to help slow the spread
of covert 19 by staying home
but what about their graduation
ceremonies learn more about ted's global
campaign to celebrate and elevate
the hopes and ideas of an entire
generation get involved at ted.com
graduation